pour mémoire design sont consacrés à
marc levy pour son dernier roman
l'étrange voyage de monsieur daldry
roman paru comme d'habitude chez robert
laffont
marc levy bonsoir bonsoir alors il ya
dans ce roman un personnage très
important qui est une voyante une
voyante de bright nord je me suis dit
que j'allais ce soir à être la voyante
de brighton
j'ai sorti ma boule de cristal pour
essayer de voir un petit peu ce qui
allait se passer pour ce rebond alors
d'abord je vois tu ce roman va être le
plus vendu en france en 2011 comme vos
romans tous depuis 2004 oui non voilà on
touche du bois
deuxièmement je vois qu'à la critique va
être un peu partagé je vois que bernard
pivot va aimer mais que par contre
frédéric beigbeder jérôme garcin mumbai
mais je me trompe beaucoup je dirais que
là ya pas besoin d'être voyant ses
dehors
pour bernard pivot je pense très très
touché oui mais je vois aussi
alors est ce que spielberg va acheter
les droits comme vous non non anglais
trop anglais trop british
alors voyons voir en quoi il est trop
british ce roman de prendre
effectivement il commence à londres en
1950 est une jeune fille alice on verra
un petit peu ses caractéristiques après
on va voir une prédiction changer toute
sa vie et l'amener à faire un voyage qui
va l'amener vers ses origines pas
seulement ses origines et se retrouver à
istanbul alors londres vous connaissez
bien il y avait vécu huit ans
aujourd'hui vous êtes à new york alors
istanbul comment ça se situe dans votre
géographie personnelle d'abord si tu
sais
une vie dont je suis tombé amoureux il
ya très longtemps je sais une des villes
les plus belles et les plus sensuelles
du monde
c'est une ville aussi de très très
grands brassages culturels c'est une
ville qui enjambe deux continents et où
on peut aller travailler le matin en
asie revenir habiter en europe
c'est une ville qui a un passé
extraordinaire et une architecture
extraordinaire et puis c'est aussi
ville qui est en turquie et la turquie
c'est un de mes grands parents et c'est
une filiation que j'ai aussi découvert
assez tardivement fin donc j'ai pris
conscience assez tardivement et c'était
assez drôle parce que j'ai toujours
voulu un grand amour pour la turquie et
[Musique]
et je me suis rendu compte finalement
que j'avais du sang turque dans mes
veines et jean des gens se j'en ai une
certaine fierté bon alors là c'est un le
roman se situe en partie à istanbul pas
parce que c'est un roman où tout
recentrer puisque c'est vraiment une
fiction mais parce que je c'est vrai que
je trouvais le
le paysage d'istanbul des années 50
extrêmement romanesque et puis alice est
née elle nous aide à son métier elle est
créatrice de parfums et puis je m'étais
fait un pari littéraire en écrivant ce
roman on dit souvent d'une écriture
qu'elle est visuel parce que je pense
que le le métier de base du romancier
c'est de créer des images dans la tête
avec des mots et là je m'étais fait le
pari de le dire est ce que c'est ce que
je pourrais réussir à créer des odeurs
avec des mots alors on va voir que dans
cette histoire la prédiction et pas
simplement istanbul il ya les personnes
c'est à dire que ces deux voyants de
brighton le dit vous allez d'abord
rencontré six personnes avant de
rencontrer la personne qui va changer ou
qu'il est le plus important dans ma vie
même si et ça c'est un élément même si
elle est peut-être passé dans votre dos
il y a un jour dit franchement oui
elle lui dit la personne qui va le plus
compté dans votre vie vient de passer
dans votre dos à l'instant mais pour la
retrouver il va falloir faire un long
voyage et de rencontrer six personnes
qui chacune à leur façon vous mèneront
jusqu'à elle est un personnage très
important c'est le voisin de palier
alors ce qui est fou et seul hic c'est
qu'on peut en parler et ne pas en parler
parce que il est tout en mystère dévoilé
et qu'il ya des choses qu'on ne peut pas
dire voilà si d'aventuré on peut dire ce
qu'on peut dire du voisin de palier
c'est que c'est un type qui est très
barré le présente
il n'est pas l'un des carrefours ils se
détestent lui même au point que y pense
que la plus belle la plus belle chose
qui puisse faire pour une femme dont il
tombera amoureux
ce serait de ne jamais se présenter à
elle pour ne surtout pas lui faire
courir le risque de rencontrer un type
comme lui il est il et il existe un aïd
et alcoolique tout en n'étant jamais
sous parce que c'est un type qui a une
et il a une autodérision hall pour les y
voilà il a un petit plan machiavélique
c'est que son rêve c'est de récupérer
l'appartement de sa voisine parce que
c'est le seul à avoir dans cette maison
mitoyenne verrière sous laquelle il
aimerait génitales voilà et est donc
cette voisine qui le gêne il trouve que
le meilleur moyen de s'en débarrasser
c'est de l'entraîner dans un voyage en
espérant que elle reste là bas alors il
y à l'huile et la peinture et les images
ll est le nez des odeurs et en
impression que les parfums sont le
meilleur chemin vers la mémoire et la
mémoire inconsciente
c'est aussi ce qu'il ya dans ce livre
c'est un peu comme le pari en faisant
des murs cherche que la mémoire
olfactive était la seule mémoire
indéfectible
cela qu'on finit par oublier les visages
on finit par oublier les laissons mais
on n'oublie jamais une odeur et la
réminiscence d'une odeur peut vous
réveiller des souvenirs que l'on croyait
éteint jamais alors si vous deviez
donner une odeur à paris à londres et à
new york
au moins le même la mémoire de l'odeur
de paris c'est l'odeur que l'on sent
très particulière quand on passe au
dessus des grilles d'aération du métro
une odeur à la fois poussiéreuse et
sucrés londres c'est une odeur de berne
mouillé new york c'est une odeur de
chanvre et de sucre et c'est une odeur
de plastique comme l'odeur des cirés
[Musique]
il est très petit chat mâle alors
beaucoup plus beau c'est l'occasion pour
notre invité de réagir sur une question
d'actualité ou quelque chose qui l'a au
mur ite ou agacer ou enthousiasmé certes
derniers temps qu'est-ce que vous avez
choisi et moi c'est un thème général
c'est à dire c'est ce qui moi ce qui me
vaut coup de gueule puisque c'est de
trouver de la critique c'est sur le
comportement politique actuelle c'est à
dire qu'on est on est confronté en ce
moment à des bouleversements majeurs
dans le monde le printemps arabe le
printemps des révolutions arabes est un
événement extraordinaire pour le monde
et je trouve que la classe politique à
défaut d'être capable de bâtir un projet
de société qui réunissent les gens ne
cesse de diviser pour mieux régner
je trouve qu'il ya un climat de
suspicion il ya un climat ne parle que
de sécurité
on
on cultive la peur chez les gens est ce
que vous sentez l'image de la france
dégradée là où vous êtes aux états unis
drake les gens avec qui vous parlez
non c'est très amusant les américains
ont une analyse de la montée du front
national qui est assez différente de
l'analyse qu'on en fait en france pour
pour beaucoup de journées afin pour
beaucoup de journalistes américains
la montée du front national en france et
était est proportionnelle à la descente
de l'udf et de l'ump du ps et c'est
beaucoup plus basses communicants lent
que cette soi disant course à la peur à
l'immigration à la peur à lindry à l'avs
à la peur de l'étranger sont toujours
une analyse républicains démocrates
oui sir cuts post un vase communicant
c'est pas tout à coup les flux
migratoires qui font voyez exploser le
front national en revanche ces quatre
années qui viennent de s'écouler ou à
droite comme à gauche on voit les
personnalités politiques qui sont plus
préoccupés par le nombril que par la
société française font qu'à un moment
donné des gens qui arrivent avec des
idées aussi basique ayral perrin cap une
attention
voilà alors oui donc c'est le moment
pour nous de déterrer le critique
concernant notre invité alors c'est
étrange quand on a parlé tout à l'heure
de deux ça faisait dix années ont trouvé
des cargaisons et ben justement on a
réparé près l'une de ces cargaisons dont
vous parlez de de critiques à propos de
marc levy mais d'une réaction d'un
papier que vous avez écrit sur les
pseudo littéraires et c'est dans le
figaro etienne de montety qui répond et
qui fait tic ce papier le romancier marc
lévy s'en va-t-en guerre de new york
on n'est jamais trop prudent marc levy
s'emporte contre ceux qu'ils nomment les
pseudo littéraires comprendre les
critiques qui ne goûte pas serment
marc lévy déplore que chacun de ses
livres soient systématiquement qualifiés
de roman de l'été genre qui est à
l'édition ce que le tube du même nom est
à la chanson pour lui rétorquera que ce
n'est pas en publiant tous les ans un
roman fin juin qu'il évitera ce
qualificatif pas plus qui n'échappera à
celui de roman de plage à moins d'
interdire à ses lectrices de glisser ses
livres dans leur sac
entre la serviette le monoï voilà
etienne de montety le figaro c'est juin
2010 alors vous voulez dire à ce sujet
mais c'est très drôle parce que cette
réaction des têtes de détiennent deux
mon physique latine est une réaction qui
a fait la couv du figaro un propos qui
jamais tenues ah bon j'ai dit il ya deux
ans où il ya un an je donne une
entretien à l afp
new york le journalisme dit à un moment
qu'est ce qu'est ce que vous pensez des
gens qui qualifie vous rend demande
roman de plage et je réponds exactement
le contraire de ce que dit cette partie
c'est à dire que j'ai dit écoutez moi je
publie mon numéro mans en été dont ils
sont lus sur la plage et je dis moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on n'est pas plus bête
sur la plage combler dans son salon et
j'ai lu et j'ai dit ça vous savez le mot
roman de plage c'est un petit peu de la
considération de snobinard littéraire
alors ce qui est amusant c'est que la
critique critique et heureusement
qu'elle critique mais il fera remarquer
que la critique aime pas beaucoup être
critiqués et qu il a suffi que je
prononce cette petite phrase que je
trouvais plutôt anodine ou aie aie aie
ça fait là ça a fait la couverture du
figaro littéraire dont conseille à mes
camarades auteurs qui ne seront jamais
dans le figaro littéraire si vous voulez
y être dit du mal de la critique vous
aurez une chance de faire la cour
[Musique]
alors là je dois filmer quand d'autres
invités à cette petite caméra
c'est une idée qui va nous emmener dans
un moment un petit peu at il dit
alors bougez pas d'abord je vais vous
filmer ce qui manque le plus à new york
si vous voulez bien
ce qui nous manque le plus à noyon voyez
c'est ça enfin moi c'est le comptoir en
zinc
mais c'est le bon vieux bistrot paris où
on va et on y entre on pleure on peut
prendre une assiette de saucisson et
qu'un morceau de baguette voilà alors
comment vous l'avez vu moi j'ai envie de
savoir marquer village et j'ai cette
image de vous travaillant ou vous êtes à
new york où vous travaillez quels sont
vos habitudes marc levy moi je travaille
dans une petite pièce
c'est dans le vieux village de new york
donc c'est dans le bas de la ville
côté ouest et je travaille dans une
petite pièce où il ya une grande
verrière ce qui est un avantage c'est
qu'il y avait beaucoup de minières mais
un inconvénient c'est comme elle c'est
une vieille verrière en faire l'hiver il
fait un froid de dents et ses 2 c'était
cet hiver où on a eu un hiver très très
dur j'ai serré la fois que j'ai écrit et
ouvrir la porte à la critique mais c'est
vraiment écrit avec des gants alors vous
êtes avec votre famille en forêt comme
endroit où j'écris c'est un atelier et
j'ai toujours essayé de lui donner ce
côté atelier oui parce que je considère
ce métier comme un artisanat et
et je vous dire en toute humilité je ne
suis pas née écrivain j'ai commencé à
écrire et j'espère que
pour autistes oui et j'espère qu'au bout
de vingt ans vingt cinq ans de travail
j'aurais mérité à force de travail le
fait d'être devenu un écrivain
ce qui est merveilleux dans le fait
d'écrire sebrango sens de toutes les
erreurs qu'on a commises dans leur
demande avant d'avoir l'espoir et
l'appétit de ne pas les commettre à
nouveau et d'avoir la lucidité d'ignorer
toutes celles qu'on va commettre et
qu'on est comique et qu'on ne connaît
pas on vous sentez encore en apporter
mais le jour où je me sentirai plus un
apprenti j'arrêterai d'écrire je
voudrais faire un petit cadeau quand tu
pars tu es un héros celle d'un été
italiart parce qu'on a pas parlé mais
vous êtes un grand amateur de cuisine
moi je me suis permis de m voilà horizon
2013 voilà comme ça voilà donc cessé fin
et donc ça me fait très plaisir parce
que je suis un fou de cuisine oui hélas
vous pouviez en plus de cuisine
italienne
voilà on parle avec vous marque à vie de
votre dernier roman l'étrange voyage de
monsieur daldry chez robert laffont
et je suis sûr que mes prédictions vont
survenir à venir
[Musique]